[Music]
the end results and humans look the same
well that is a good question you know if
you look at this picture here later on
but you can see how different they are I
mean let me just ask you straight
forward can you tow it to the - is the
Neanderthal skull yeah it's obvious that
you know they were different in fact
there is there are quite a bit of
descriptions here you have one from
Chris stringer know about 2013 decoding
and athos he says the following says we
can tell an Annabelle skull 100% of the
time 100% of time you can tell a nano
thought skull that's how different they
were and you can see from those from
that picture you don't need to be an
expert you can look and say well you
know there is a difference this guy's an
ape and we are not so we look quite a
bit different here's a description now
from you Rach History Channel 2,000
secrets of the Stone Age
she says the following and Athos
developed a very unique facial
architecture it's as if somebody took
the face and pulled them and the rest of
the face is stretching behind another
thing that is very distinct in homo
sapiens is the fact that we do have a
chin this protuberance is absent
completely from the mandible of Nandor
thoughts
so these guys look different I think you
would recognize an end of thought if you
walked up there in the forest and saw
one he would look probably more like a
gorilla I have to believe that he had
hair all over his body and and that's
because he had no reason to lose it you
know and the question pops up why did we
lose our hair because we are probably
the only hominid that lost it so there
are differences between these
Neanderthals and us you know and so the
question also comes up in the case
that mixture with the hairiness we don't
know how much hair they actually had
there's no skull that has the hairs
attached to it doesn't it yeah anytime
we're talking about here where it's
speculation I believe yeah we we haven't
found a hair you know on the body or you
know skin or anything like that from the
end of those of you that we have no idea
what the external aspect of methought
was like all we can do is theorize based
on you know just the ideas that we have
on what we think they might have had the
surrounding circumstances of where
they're found
how far along ago they were found so you
kinda have to put the puzzle pieces
around it to figure out what they
actually looked like yeah and you know
if we part from this base that Homo
erectus left Africa 1.8 million years
ago we found something in the country
called Georgia right and it's data to
that to 1.8 million years ago we know
that there was some kind of harm and in
England about at least seven or eight
hundred thousand years ago we assume
it's Homo erectus or perhaps a
Heidelberg lovell maybe homo ancestor
and and of course how did they live
because throughout this time we had
glaciers they extended all the way to
England so these these hominids were
living in a very very cold region these
directives were living in Africa and
Europe then Europe Africa and Asia any
number but in the case of Asia they were
they were lower you know they were
closer to the equator but in Europe they
were close to Arctic and they were close
to the glacier areas right
they were north in the northern part of
France they were in the northern part of
German
and they were in England you know so not
the Neanderthals perhaps but for sure
some hominid that preceded age yeah this
was an ice age so the question is how
did this hominid live in this cold
weather
he had no clothes and and so what have
they done in order to accommodate at mr.
theory which is the interbreeding theory
that says you know that humans and
Neanderthals interbred and we are their
offspring over the years you know
they've they've modified the mandala and
one thing you will note is that you know
here I have a picture of it you'll see
that at the beginning of the 20th
century right they had an Anitha looked
like this ape that you see there and
over time this ape lost his hair
miraculously
and they eventually had to put him in
clothes so they made him look ever more
human just to accommodate this this
admixture theory they did this because
it's inconceivable that we would make a
breed with anything without clothes well
let's first look at the guys before the
clothes do you think a woman would sleep
with a one in 2013 or the one in 1909 I
mean you know if a woman saw the one in
1909 she could run for the hills but you
know she might be willing to sleep with
the other guy so so I mean yeah if you
make the end it'll look like us
you know shrink his head a little bit
say well we put some clothes on he would
look like the ordinary businessman well
yeah then people are more willing to
accept it mixture theory but this is not
science this is just propaganda that's
all it is
you know they had to look different and
one of the things one of the features
the outer because what's morphology
morphology is the external appearance of
an animal of any animal
if a poodle is different than a Doberman
right they're from the same species as
we discussed yesterday but there are two
different races they can still mate have
children be able children
but they don't drastically different so
you might think that there are two
different species but they're the same
species are the species of bomb right
but they have different morphology
different appearance and in the case of
Nanda fell the question is whether they
were a different species or just a
different race yeah and and the first
issue is if we came across an ANA Thal
would he be dressed
would he be nude did Nana Thals wear
clothes because that is someone the
external appearance of what you would
see it up there in the wild if an
antelope comes close well you said why
he looks more or less like me but if
he's just a gorilla you know with this
hairs hanging all over the question
would a woman who is dressed you know
not recognize that that's a different
species so maybe it's the same situation
like the Doberman and the poodle where
they recognize that it looks completely
different but they still go ahead and
breathe yeah that could be it but I
think we have to establish whether they
had clothes or not because I think
that's an added piece there in other
words if Nandor dolls were nude like a
gorilla and we come in dressed you know
we're we have different heads to begin
with you recognize this guy with a big
nose flattened head you know and cetera
and you say well he looks different but
when you don't see him with any clothes
and you are wearing clothes that's got
to you know it's like the missionary's
when they go into the jungle and here we
see these uh you know these people
they're completely nude and and we're
dressed what do they think of lesson it
makes you kind of wonder you know what
goes in Atlanta where did this guy dress
what is that thing that he's got on what
is it it's so hard what is he putting
this on you know so that's got a that's
got a cause already some kind of barrier
some kind of you know you wake up on it
and I wonder if dogs stay away from dogs
that's all
about something that you're putting on
over the body and it speaks to a certain
culture it mentioned the Neanderthal man
and earth always looking at us and we're
dressed right in the cold weather so
what is he putting clothes on it's warm
today brings us three degrees below zero
yeah it means the whole idea of culture
behind it because if these people are
dressed in some art then the people that
address have a little culture around
being dressed well the people that don't
see that and like okay these guys are
very different from us
it's a another layer of difference
besides the skull size so the point that
I'm trying to make here is that we need
to determine when clothes were infected
because that even though I mean the
skull is one thing but then the rest of
the body is either closed or not close
to me there's your shoes or we don't use
one of the other and in the point here
is that didn't and adults have clothes
did they invent clothes and again we go
back to homo erectus who was already in
England either him or Heidelberg one of
the two was already in England seven
hundred eight hundred thousand years ago
there was some kind of hominid there we
found her tools we didn't find them in a
skeleton but we found the tools I think
they found some a couple years ago they
found also some body parts but the point
is he was already living in England
eight hundred thousand years ago arctic
weather glaciers just you know came all
the way to England and the questions how
did he do it he certainly didn't have
clothes but he had tools
well he had tools yeah but he didn't be
clothed he had adapted over thousands of
years to the cold climates like a monkey
with a spear yeah and then from him a
singing that was correctness you know
and then we go from direct us to
Heidelberg and for heidelburgh tun
Amazon right so over the thousands of
years these are the grew the type
stepping fine you know the skeletons and
heads and so on that we find over time
did at some point did any of these
hominids have claws
[Music]
yeah tell what should we do with that
mixture theorists now let me tell you
what I think
[Music]